you just got some rhubarb from the
allotment brenda
oh that's good yeah look you got it in
the bag
this isn't how they imagined their
retirement together would be
dementia is making brenda whittle
increasingly forgetful
her husband stephen helpless unable to
stop the deterioration
in his wife's health when she was
diagnosed
six years ago it came as a shock to them
both
i was a bit angry i think yeah she was
very angry
because when you know what is going to
happen to you
and you can look look ahead and you can
see what is going to happen in the
future it
must be terribly frightening and it
certainly was for brenda
you know it is
a horrible disease really in that you
know that um
things aren't can't get any better
brenda was found to have high
cholesterol when she was in her early
forties
now a major study has linked high levels
of cholesterol in middle age with an
increased risk of dementia
later in life and gooseberries you were
picking gooseberries as well
when brenda and stephen have this
message
for younger adults well certainly
we we would say to them you know eat a
good diet
you know make sure that you don't eat
things which is going to excessively
raise your cholesterol and maybe you
know in
in your late 30s 40s get tested and
if your heart are high cholesterol well
go on to the statins the research
involved more than 1.8 million adults in
the uk
they were all aged over 40 and had a
blood cholesterol measurement
taken between 1992 and 2009
people who had a higher level of a type
of cholesterol known as low density
lipoprotein before the age of 65
had a 60 percent greater risk of being
diagnosed with dementia
more than a decade later
this research adds high cholesterol to
other known risk factors which include
excessive alcohol drinking
head injuries and exposure to air
pollution in the uk today we estimate
that over 850 000 people are living with
dementia
and that number is very likely to
increase to around a million by 2025 so
that's a huge
figure research shows that around 40
of cases may be preventable so there are
steps that we can take to prevent those
cases
some factors are easy to tackle some
factors are more difficult but it's
really important that people are aware
that
dementia is not just a natural part of
aging and there are things that we can
do to reduce our risk like
keeping ourselves active eating well
looking after our cardiovascular health
the hope of researchers and those
suffering with this cruel disease
is a greater understanding of how to
prevent it will lead to fewer people
suffering
becky johnson sky news